the Sun can give life but it can also
destroy and the coronavirus may not be
impervious to its power a ray of hope in
a beam of ultraviolet light it can help
but it can also harm scientists are
working on ways to make it safer for
people at a time where there still no
cure or vaccine for kovat 19 can UV
light illuminate a way out of a global
pandemic the question welcome toooo
covered 19 special here on dnews
I'm Monica Jones and Willem good to have
you with us now the case numbers are
falling in Europe but we don't know for
sure if a warm weather is killing off
the virus or if it's just taking a break
we shouldn't take chances but we could
learn from the Sun and it's powerful UV
light they start work when the shops
closed it's safer if they don't come in
direct contact with staff or customers
these little robots are coronavirus
assassins their weapon is UVC light UVC
is the only known way in which you can
disinfect the air so as you know one
Kobe 19 loss in the air for a couple of
hours for other forms if you wipe down
just webbing on the surface you can wipe
the air UVC light can kill 99% of all
pathogens in the air and is very
effective at disinfecting surfaces
similar robots are being used in subways
and buses like here in Argentina
hello ultraviolet arsenal ooh
ultraviolet light is the light that the
Sun emits naturally in this case we use
type C which is very high-energy and
works by destroying the DNA of the
bacteria and the RNA in the case of
viruses thus avoiding propagation or
spread UVC light kills all
microorganisms but does not occur
naturally it has to be generated
artificially the Sun produces UV a B and
C light the C light is filtered out by
the Earth's atmosphere otherwise there
would be no life on earth doctors advise
against exposing yourself to direct UVC
light it's the most powerful level of
ultraviolet light there is and is
especially dangerous for the skin and
eyes
and for more let's bring in dr.
Charlotte Holt Kraft she's a viral
adjust at Cambridge infectious diseases
and interdisciplinary research center at
the University of Cambridge good to have
you with us could we start first of all
looking at the virus itself what happens
to a virus when it's exposed to UV see
so a number of different chemicals or
germicidal treatments can be used to try
and disrupt viruses on surfaces and UVC
specifically mutates the genetic
material and viruses and it works it
works particularly well when the virus
genome is smaller so fewer letters in
the genetic code and that particularly
applies to the new corona virus all
scoff - which is 30 thousand base pairs
long
and does the obviously than the render
the virus inactive but still alive or
does it actually destroy it completely
so it's rendering it inactive so
incapable of infecting new cells and
capable of causing new infections but if
you looked for its genetic material on a
surface after UVC treatment I would
expect that you would still be able to
find some of the genetic material there
you just wouldn't be able to find
infectious particles which is what we
really care about right so in this in
this fight against the current pandemic
how effective is UVC when used against
sashko - there's still only limited
evidence of the usefulness of UVC
against saw squab - specifically it
certainly can be used to deactivate or
inactivate other similar viruses from
the same corona virus family but there
are also risks associated with UVCE
treatment it's particularly toxic to
humans it can cause cataracts it can
cause skin cancer so there are there are
costs of benefits associated with using
UVC for virus inactivation right so what
we saw on this report is that UVC is
mostly used like in buses at night when
they don't run when there's no people in
it
but how big a chance do you think there
is for UVC killing off the virus let's
say in school classrooms as kids are
returning to schools offices shopping
malls to all those enclosed places rooms
that that actually were part of our
daily lives before the pandemic hit UVC
is certainly one option for deactivating
viruses on surfaces in enclosed spaces
one of the problems is that you require
specialist equipment in this case
specialist bulbs to make the UVC light
that would need to be installed in all
of these places you only get an
activation of the virus on surfaces that
are hit directly by the lights so
anything that's in the shade of another
object would not have successful viral
killing so I think EVC is only going to
be one tool alongside classical
classical options for killing the
viruses on surfaces such as very good
surface cleaning with with soap and
water or with ethanol or with other
household disinfectants so UVC is part
of the solution but it is not the
solution in itself now of course we know
that some corona viruses are seasonal
like the annual flu and indeed case
numbers here in Europe where where
summer is approaching you can feel it in
the air are falling does this mean that
sashko 2 is also affected by warmth and
sunlight yes there's good evidence to
show that natural UV wavelengths that
come from sunlight are quite effective
in activating the new corona virus and a
study was done simulating the amount of
UV that you get from midday Sun in Spain
in in the middle of the year around the
time of year that we have now showing
that midday Sun in Spain would
inactivate the virus on services after
about seven minutes and at that kind of
latitude even in December in bright
sunlight you would see the virus
inactivated after about 15 minutes so we
will find that over the summer there's
less infectious viruses all the surfaces
that we might all be touching in the
open air but actually it's likely that
the the natural distancing that people
are taking part in during the summer is
is one of the most effective ways of
stopping the spread of the virus we're
all spread out more because when were
out door
there's that constant dilution of fresh
air and that may actually be as powerful
or more powerful than changes in UV or
temperature all right then we have to
make the most of the summer months ahead
and hope for a sunny winter dr.
Charlotte Holt craft from the University
of Cambridge thank you so much for your
time thanks for having me
a now it's time for your questions over
to our science correspondent Derek
Williams if Co vid 19 invades many
bodily fluids and organs is it possible
for it to enter a fetus though there's
still a lot we don't know about the
virus and the field of reproductive
medicine at this stage the chances of a
mother passing it along to an unborn
child appear to be very low and in one
study that looked at 38 expectant
Chinese mothers who became infected with
kovat 19 none of the babies that were
subsequently born tested positive for
the virus from another that tracked 33
pregnant women in China confirmed that
three of the babies born to them also
tested positive for the disease but as
all three were delivered by caesarean
section it was unclear whether they
caught it before during or after birth
so even if the virus does cross the
placenta in some cases it would seem to
be a pretty rare event there are hot
spots in the meat industry in the US and
Germany is that because meat products
can be contagious
workers at meatpacking plants in many
countries have been coming down with
kovat 19 and in far greater numbers than
the people who work in other industries
so so what's going on like so much about
this disease it still isn't is it really
clear but there are our plenty of
guesses one involves proximity workers
in meatpacking plants spend a lot of
time close to each other working fast
and the work can be physically very
taxing many people will be breathing
hard
it probably isn't easy to keep
protective gear like like masks in place
and and social distancing is very
difficult the the low temperatures in
facilities also probably play a role the
virus likely remains viable for longer
at low temperatures
experts therefore believe that the
problem isn't that meat can carry the
contagion but instead a whole range of
other issues surrounding this kind of
work do lipid levels increase during
active kovat 19 interestingly several
studies have so far shown that it
actually appears to be the opposite one
that looked at blood work performed on
nearly 600 patients discovered that not
only does cholesterol in the blood sink
in patients who have kovat 19 how far it
drops also seems to correlate with
disease severity some experts even now
believe lipid levels could be used to
predict how badly someone is going to
react to getting covin 19 the question
is is is why do those levels drop one
theory is that cholesterol from the
blood is being loaded into various
tissues and and that's contributing in
some way to the deadly progression of
the disease that might for example
explain why older people who start out
with high levels of cholesterol are so
much more effective than for example
kids who generally have have low
cholesterol levels it's an interesting
working hypothesis I think but it's but
it's still unproven
[Music]
it's not just disinfecting robots using
ultraviolet light - who are gaining
their place in the Sun the need for
social distancing means service robots
are starting to become more popular -
these two work in a Chinese restaurant
and a Netherlands with a touch of a
button they deliver orders to tap tables
reactions from diners have however been
mixed with some enjoying the novelty and
others bemoaning the lack of
interpersonal contact and we still don't
know if they need to be tipped